[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes à un moment critique dans
cette guerre contre les japonais
les enfants il faut que nous allions les
chercher
en tant que nouvelle recrue je n'espère
pas vous voir à battre tous les héros
que vous allez croiser
radiation n'est ni entraîner ni équipés
hors de question envoyé six gamins se
faire descendre en vol
et merde
[Musique]
monsieur permettez nous d'aller leur
péter la gueule
faut qu'on en finisse
c'est la bataille finale le japon a de
très bons pilotes
alors nous nous allons combattre ces
[ __ ]
si tu n'es pas prêt à se battre pour ce
que tu aimes ça veut dire que tu ne
méritais pas
devoir c'est de protéger vos mères vos
pères est aussi beaux enfants
moi
[Musique]
votre espérance de vie est très courte 5
jours maximum